camee is with us in Columbia South
Carolina hi Tammy welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hi Dave thanks for taking my
call sure what's up in your world well I
need affirmation that it's okay to evict
my 22 year old son from the house that
he rents from me because he's not paying
rent mm-hmm and he literally won't move
unless you go through the legal process
to evict him right Wow
this has gotten kind of inches I'm sorry
there's a grandchild involved too which
is why I involved or lives their lives
there he lives there with his girlfriend
and his son oh I see so why is it so
contentious that he won't pay rent and
or won't move well that's a good
question because he he has two years of
electrical training so he could work a
job that pays probably close to $20 an
hour but he doesn't want to do that so
he works for nine bucks in a restaurant
I don't mind that if he pays his rent
keeps no how much is the rent well I
have him pay the mortgage payments which
is only five hundred twenty dollars and
then I pay all the utilities and so the
payment that they pay me total to be
about seven hundred forty dollars a
month which is very reasonable yeah and
the house would rent for normally how
much um about eleven hundred okay all
right so let me ask you this I'm a
little bit confused because if you were
to sit down with him and said girlfriend
and say okay look here's the thing if
you're not going to pay the rent you
have to move what would they say well
we're trying because I've had that
conversation with them before we're
trying I'll pay you extra next week that
kind of stuff
now I can afford it but the fact that I
know that's not that's not it you're in
here enabling him he's acting like he's
four years old yeah I'm not worried
about you being paid I think regardless
of whether he pays you or not
this is starting to drive an unhealthy
wedge in your all's relationship and you
don't want to lose contact with your
grams grandchild so what I would do is
just sit down and say you know what
forget the whole thing it doesn't work
so has nothing to do with you paying the
rent or anything else it's caught this
this whole thing of me being your
landlord it's not it was supposed to be
a blessing and it's causing a problem
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to sell the house and you all know
you all need to move by the end of you
know by the end of January okay and so
I'm going to I'm going to give you to
the end of January as a matter of fact
just don't even pay me rent you get free
rent from now until the end of January
and that will help you save up to make
your move because we're going to sell
the house the house is going on the
market the end of January if you're not
out of the house in the January then
then son and girlfriend we're going to
have a problem because I'm gonna sue
your butt and throw you in the street
like you're a deadbeat so don't be a
deadbeat let's just do this like real
grown-up people and sweet people I'm
going to give you free freaking rents
everybody say free rent I'm going to
give you free freakin rent through the
end of January because you can afford it
this is more about your relationship and
more about him becoming a man right he
knows better that's the thing he's been
taught better so yeah but he's got a bad
influence and we all know who she is
thank you oh well can you just say you
can look in through the radio and see it
right now I can see you right now so you
need to sit waiting army I think
responsibility for his yeah yeah
absolutely say you and your husband need
to sit down with the two of them you
could take them to dinner in a nice
restaurant and just just say I got good
news and I got bad news the good news is
we love you so much that we're not going
to be your landlord anymore because it's
not working it's breaking our heart we
feel bad all the
and you feel bad and we don't want to be
that so here's what we've decided to do
we're going to sell the house it's going
on the market February the first so you
have to be gone by February the first
the good news is you get free rent until
then I'm going to pay everything and and
you got to move and rather than because
I'm what I'm more concerned with here is
that you all end up with a relationship
even if it's a weird one because there's
weirdness here and you can stay in
contact with your grandbaby and
everything else and otherwise there's no
there's no fixing this because it's the
pattern of how this deal went down is so
screwed up yeah and you've allowed it
for so long that now when the excuses
come you don't believe them but if you
say that it's going to just put you in a
you know you're trying to fix his
character and he needs to go fix his
character one and he'll he'll go for
help a his new landlord that's one I bet
he does to our Betty gets thrown in the
street one of the two that's how life
works and then you get yeah then you
become a man my son
mmhmm yeah and oh you know what you
could pay for him to go through four
I'll do it let me give you a Financial
Peace University send a couple through
Financial Peace University let's teach
you how to handle money
thank you so much yeah let's just you
and me let's just be a blessing to them
and get them the crap out of that house
good lord what a mess hold on Kelly I'll
pick up we'll put them in financial
peace this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
enjoyed that video from the Dave Ramsey
show if you want to watch another great
video check out my video three things
you should consider renting right over
here or click the link in the
description below